[Music]
what's the latest diet trend this year
that can help me lose weight
does this sound familiar
every year
new fat diets pop up with promises that
drastically changing your diet can help
you lose sweet but in reality this type
of quick fix weight loss doesn't last
how many of you have been on a diet how
many times have you failed let me know
in the comments below
if you really want to go on a diet and
drop the pounds for good your best bet
is to adopt healthy habits that you will
be able to maintain over the long term
so ask yourself these questions before
settling on a new diet
is this diet sustainable for me meaning
can you do it 7 days a week or forever
is this diet overly restrictive if you
are going to feel deprived well
trust me it will be tough to stick to it
because eventually those cravings will
take over
will you be able to live your life while
on it that means will you be able to
have a social life and still enjoy meals
out with your family and friends will
you be adequately nourished this is the
most important question to ask yourself
if you're restricting and depriving your
body of the nutrient it needs to
function it's going to do more harm than
good just keep this in mind the best
diet is the one that doesn't feel like a
diet the plant incorporates all food
groups teaches you about portion sizes
and provides healthy cooking tips in
fact the best diet is actually not a
diet but a lifestyle which you can
sustain forever
so
after going through an endless list of
diets here are my top three best diets
which have been scientifically proven to
help you lose weight and maintain a
healthy weight for life i'll be sharing
with you the food portions and how you
can easily incorporate them into your
daily life
a healthy balanced diet means eating a
variety of foods from each major food
group from proteins and carbohydrates to
fruits and vegetables even if you're in
good health you should still avoid
highly processed foods and added sugars
so a typical healthy balanced macro
breakdown would be 50 carbs 30 fat and
20 protein to keep it simple your
healthy plate should look like this
half vegetables quarter protein and
quarter cups so aim to fill your plate
with a variety of colorful vegetables as
they are a great source of vitamins
minerals antioxidants and dietary fiber
so aim to consume two to three servings
of vegetables in each meal here's what a
serving of vegetables looks like
one cup of raw leafy greens such as
spinach or lettuce half a cup of chunky
vegetables such as broccoli florets bell
peppers and carrots or
half a cup of vegetable juice you can
also add a piece of fruit to your meal
or
simply have it as a snack
as for protein choose high quality
proteins such as chicken breasts fish
meat tempeh tofu beans and legumes so
the general recommendation is about 0.8
grams of protein per kilo of your body
weight but if you lead an active
lifestyle then consume between 1.2 to
1.7 grams of protein per kilo of your
body weight for example if you weigh 54
kilos and you consume about 1.5 grams of
protein per kilo of your body weight
that means you should be consuming about
81 grams of protein in a day
so how you can achieve that is to
consume two eggs for breakfast
one portion of salmon for lunch
half a cup of greek yogurt as your snack
and one portion of white fish for dinner
this gives you a total of 81 grams of
protein so protein is extremely
important to repair and build muscle
tissue transport and store nutrients and
coordinate bodily functions
as for carbohydrates choose healthy
complex cups such as rice quinoa oats
buckwheat noodles sweet potatoes pumpkin
whole grain pasta or wholemeal bread
the main function of carbohydrate is to
provide your body with energy for
example if you consume 1 800 calories a
day and 50 of that is carbs that means
your daily cup intake is about 225 grams
and how you can simply achieve that is
to consume two slices of bread for
breakfast
one small bowl of rice for lunch one
small bowl of rice for dinner
a banana as your snack
a medium baked sweet potato
and
not forgetting your five servings of
vegetables that gives you a total of 220
grams of carbs in a day and as for
healthy fats you can easily integrate
them into your diet by using olive oil
in your cooking and consuming oily fish
peanut butter avocado nuts and seeds
healthy fats keep the heart healthy
protect your organs and support cell
growth and provide energy
so here's what one serving of healthy
fats look like one tablespoon of oil or
butter one ounce of nuts half an avocado
and fats from 4 ounces of salmon fillet
now remember to consume them in small
quantities as they are calorie dense so
this is a general guideline for the
healthy balanced diet the goal here is
to consume a wide variety of foods in
moderation by keeping to your daily
calorie needs and macros and of course
you can still enjoy your occasional
treats of processed foods and desserts
but keep them in small quantities
remember the key here is balance and
moderation
this next diet has been voted as the
best diet year after year it is the
mediterranean diet so what's the
mediterranean diet and why is it so
popular and effective for weight loss
the mediterranean diet incorporates the
traditional healthy living habits of
people from the mediterranean region so
this diet is essentially low in carbs
low in saturated fats and high in
unsaturated fats it puts a higher focus
on plant foods and cooking using healthy
fats such as olive oil with plenty of
flavorful spices
so following this diet can improve
healthy cholesterol levels and keep
blood sugar levels in a healthy range
now remember there's no one right method
to follow the mediterranean diet but
here are some basic rules you can start
with consume a wide variety of
vegetables fruits whole grains beans
nuts
herbs spices and unsaturated fats such
as olive oil daily consume fish and
other seafood twice weekly consume a
moderate portion of poultry eggs cheese
yogurt
as well as red wine and only
occasionally consume red meat and sweets
so a general portion breakdown for this
diet will consist of 50 cups
35 to 40 fats and 15 to 20 protein so
people following this diet would either
limit or avoid their consumption of
refined grains refined oil added sugars
sugar-sweetened beverages
processed meats and other highly
processed foods
the mediterranean diet believes that
whole single ingredient foods are often
crucial to good health therefore to
start building your own mediterranean
diet recipes you'll want to stock up on
whole grains such as whole oats brown
rice rye bread barley buckwheat and
whole grain pasta tubers such as
potatoes sweet potatoes and yams
vegetables such as lettuce spinach
onions broccoli carrots and cucumber
fruits such as tomatoes apples bananas
nectarines strawberries dragon fruit and
dates
nuts and seeds which includes almonds
cashews walnuts sunflower seeds and
pumpkin seeds
legumes which includes beans lentils
peas
pulses and chickpeas
seafood such as salmon mackerel white
fish shrimp and shellfish poultry such
as chicken and eggs healthy fats such as
olives olive oil and avocados dairy such
as greek yogurt milk and cheese and
finally herbs and spices so the
mediterranean way of eating is generally
rich in healthy plant foods and
relatively low in animal products and
meats with a focus on fish and seafood
so following this diet long term can
improve your weight and prevent certain
health issues such as heart disease
stroke and type 2 diabetes
and the final best diet for weight
management is the low carb diet this
diet limits your cup intake which
encourages your body to use more fat as
fuel
if you know that you have a higher
sensitivity towards cups and your body
has a higher resistance to insulin then
the low carb diet may work well for you
insulin is the hormone responsible for
controlling your blood sugar levels so a
high level of insulin resistance means
that your blood sugar levels are likely
to spike after consuming cups especially
refined cups
so some of the common signs of carb
sensitivity include intense craving for
refined cups
struggling with always feeling hungry
which can lead to overeating energy
level dips after an hour of consuming
cups you tend to gain weight easily
and you experience cup withdrawal
symptoms such as headaches irritability
mood swings and anxiety carb sensitivity
is a real thing and it just might be the
reason why weight loss can be
challenging for you
now if you fall under this category it
doesn't mean that you cannot consume
carbs at all but you need to choose the
good cups and limit your portion
your goal is to choose non-starchy
colorful vegetables high quality
proteins and healthy fats
let's first understand what are carbs
carbs are an essential part of a healthy
diet however it is very important to
know that not all cups are created equal
so how then do we differentiate between
good carbs and bad cups
good cups are complex cups which are
unprocessed and contain fiber found
naturally in food
so these examples include quinoa oats
buckwheat noodle brown rice sweet
potatoes pumpkin and beans they are
loaded with nutrients and fiber and
provide sustained energy on the other
hand
bad cups are refined cups which have
been processed and had the natural fiber
removed or changed examples include
cereal cakes pastries biscuits pizza
sodas and added sugars they are usually
lacking in nutrients hence they are
referred to as empty calories so our
bodies process refined cups quickly and
they do not provide lasting energy and
this can cause a spike in blood sugar
levels and the goal here is to reduce or
avoid all refined carbs in your diet
so a low carb diet macro breakdown would
be 15 to 25 cups 40 to 50 protein
and 25 to 30 fat
you want to limit your cup intake to
about 100 to 150 grams per day and the
key here is to limit starchy cups and
aim to consume more non-starchy cups so
aim to consume only about two to three
servings of starchy cups in a day so for
example half a cup of oats for breakfast
1 small bowl of cooked brown rice for
lunch and around 150 grams of sweet
potatoes for dinner on the other hand
you can increase your protein portion to
2 servings in each meal so for example
you can have cheesy tuna omelette for
breakfast
2 portions of chicken breast for lunch
2 servings of fish for dinner and 1 cup
of greek yogurt topped with nuts and
seeds as your snack so having a high
protein diet will keep you full for
longer stabilize your blood sugar levels
and reduce cravings as for healthy fats
again you can easily integrate them into
your diet by using olive oil in your
cooking and consuming oily fish peanut
butter avocado nuts and seeds
healthy fats keep the heart healthy
protect your organs support cell growth
and provide energy so when you are carb
sensitive consuming carb rich foods has
a greater impact on your overall
well-being than merely reducing your
calorie intake therefore you need to pay
more attention to the types of carbs you
consume
just know that diets aren't just for
weight loss while changing your diet can
be one of the best ways to lose weight
it can also be a gateway to improving
your habits focusing on your health and
leading a more active lifestyle
although the three diets have been shown
to be effective for weight loss the diet
you choose should depend on your
lifestyle and food preferences
this will ensure that you are more
likely to stick to it in the long term
now remember this is just a guideline
for you to understand each diet before
starting any new kind of diet it is
always a good idea to talk with your
doctor about your personal health
history they can always help you decide
which plan would work best for you so
let me know which is your preferred diet
in the comments below and don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up and share
it on with your friends as well okay
and what other topics would you like to
learn more of let me know in the
comments below don't forget to also hit
the subscribe button if you haven't yet
done it go on to my channel to learn
more about healthy food recipes as well
as check out a lot more workout videos
and mindset tips and i will see you next
time all the best